hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well early on in
his dialogue which is named the gorgeous
after one of the main interlocutors of
Socrates and you can even say the
pretext for having the dialogue in the
first place at the house of calculus
Socrates is going to speak with Gorgeous
himself and gorgeous is this rhetorician
who can also teach other people rhetoric
and they've talked a little bit already
about the nature of the art and its
morality and now Socrates will make a
kind of offhand comment that turns out
to be incredibly insightful and
important and it applies even today to
arguments that people get into with each
other whether in real life you know or
just purely virtual online places is or
everything in between it's when people
start out discussing a topic and they
start to get upset with each other and
attribute all sorts of motives to the
other person and you could say well this
is kind of basic human psychology that
Socrates is sketching out and it's
something that we want to be aware of
and on guard about this particular
Dynamic and so Socrates is talking with
gorgeous and he you know he's talking
and saying uh gorgeous you're this kind
of person but we could also assume this
is Socrates himself saying this the same
about himself they're both experienced
in the Greek word for that is emperion
right the word that we get empiricism
from uh experience having seen things a
lot and experienced in what in having
and holding and observing discussions
many discussions actually pull on logon
logos is a Greek term which can mean
very important big things like reason or
rationality or language or speech but it
also means particular
communication instances right so
speeches that people give or discourses
or things that they write down or
conversations that they have with each
other and this is what he has in mind
here discussions or conversations and he
says that you know you've observed in
the Greek word for that is
right this is a perfect of this this
verb which is a composite you've
actually like seen you've you've looked
down and observed these sorts of things
it's implying that there's a kind of
Detachment there as well and what is he
what is he going to have seen what does
Socrates say that he and gorgeous have
both observed well the first thing is
that a lot of people want to begin from
definitions right Define this what's
your definition of this and Socrates
says and he's he's completely right
about this so speakers people who are
talking can rarely Define the subjects
that they are
literally in the Greek placing their
hands upon right the things that they're
going to be
examining together and a lot of times
people will give definitions and the
definitions aren't really any good
they're tendentious they're based on
insufficient knowledge so you know
Finding real definitions is pretty
tricky and the Greek word for this
diorisa menoi right so horos is a
boundary or that's what the we actually
translate is definition so the do is
kind of an intensifier here right they
are they're not able to really wrap
their their linguistic chops around the
things that they're supposed to be
knowledgeable about and notice uh dioris
menoi Pros they're not able to do this
in relation to each other it's not just
that they're not able to provide a
definition Lots sometimes people provide
definitions in Socratic dialogues they
turn out to be not very good ones you
define in relation to your interlocutor
towards the person that you are having a
conversation with right you're trying to
get to the bottom of something together
and so because of this they don't wind
up engaging in as the translation runs
here a little bit kind of uh elevated
language they don't uh wind up having
Mutual instruction and Enlightenment but
it's actually much more uh you know we
could say straightforward in the Greek
we could call it Mutual instruction or
Mutual teaching and learning
right and uh dedoxone taste so uh the
dedoxone faces the teaching and the
motham tastes the learning right and
again notice hey autus right in relation
to each other
so again Socrates is stressing that
these situations are not just like
somebody throwing a deluge of words at
the other person and then waiting for
the other person to respond it's back
and forth you're trying to go somewhere
with that person
and so you know when we get to uh
disputed matters
right and this is uh so the amphi both
two sides right uh you know having a uh
amphi beta scene here is a dispute a
debate there are two sides at least to
the story so in the matter that they're
actually
disputing about with each other one
person may say that the other one speaks
or says things or articulates legging a
very important Greek word wrongly me
orthos literally not straight but it
also means incorrectly right or
unclearly may sapphos now pause for a
second and think about online
discussions where you see people over
and over and over again accusing their
opponents of getting things wrong being
unclear sometimes that's the case
sometimes not if somebody says I don't
understand what you're saying what
you're the the way in which you're
talking about this is less clear than it
ought to be you have a possibility there
you can say oh well let me see if I can
re-explain it or you could start to
get angry at the other person and that
is indeed what happens and very
interestingly Socrates uses the plural
here right and through the rest of us
they get angry and the particular term
for getting angry there
right which is coming from uh hadapos
being difficult being a pain in the ass
to the other person wanting to be a
stickler about stuff but also getting
irritated with them this isn't like a
full-blown rage where you're weighed you
know wandering and punching people and
stepping on them or you know foaming at
the mouth but it's a kind of anger so
they get angry with each other why
because they assume that the other
person is speaking out of malice or
actually phonos jealousy Envy towards
them right towards what it is that they
have to say now
why would you be envious
well you could be envious of the other
person's time attention that they're
getting from other people
why do they get to talk about this when
I'm the expert I I know about it think
about through simicus and how angry he
gets in Republic book one listening to
these dummies talk about the nature of
justice and get it wrong when I've got
the doctrine of justice so people do get
quite angry and they think that the
other person is speaking the way that
they are to them out of some sort of
malicious point of view and what else is
involved with this wanting to win a sort
of rivalry right as it has here being
more anxious for verbal Victory so
filonica is something that gets talked
about quite a lot in Plato and in other
virtue ethicists in ancient Greece it
means this tendency literally it's a
desire or a love for victory to to beat
out other people
so you see this a lot in in discussions
don't you some people just want to be
right and everybody else needs to be
wrong unless they agree with them some
people are more eager to score verbal or
you could say symbolic victories than do
anything else some people just want to
humiliate others this is a common
Dynamic and so you could feel that
yourself towards the other person or you
could be attributing that to the other
person and then you're like hey I don't
like that person over there who is
trying to win and doesn't really care
this is the other part not really
seeking to grasp
the matters that are under discussion
and the word for seeking or
investigating there zetu zetuntas right
the the word for seeking out the word
for investigating right so when we're
actually having a good faith discussion
we're talking with other people and they
get to make their points and we make our
points and we don't get too bound up
with it being my point or your point
we're interested in seeking out the
truth somebody who's motivated by a
filonikia by this desire to succeed to
win to be the dominant person they're
not so interested in the truth it's
great if things are true it's great if
things turn out to confirm their point
of view but they're perfectly fine also
uh having their point of view
acknowledged
but not being completely right just
people saying that it's right and so
Socrates says that this often ends in
shameful Behavior
Behavior behavior that is uh
embarrassing behavior that should be
shameful to the people involved and even
verbal abuse and the Greek word for this
you know
um you could you could actually look at
it as like placing abuse on the other
person or hurling abuse at the other
person and this is unfortunately I would
say just as common maybe even more
common in our own time in many of the
engagements that we see they you know uh
bad faith uh engagements with other
people it's just as common or more
common in our time than perhaps it was
in the ancient degrees in which Socrates
is saying hey gorgeous haven't you
observed this Dynamic happen over and
over again so there's a lot of handles
by which we can pick this up we can
think about this as why people actually
do get angry and irritated and hostile
with each other in discussions they
don't you know they pick topics that are
kind of messy and then they start
attributing
um bad motivations rather than good
motivations to the other people Perhaps
rightly Perhaps wrongly they may also be
subject to that themselves and
projecting it onto the other person and
you know we could also look at this as a
dynamic that has to do with what it is
that we ought to be doing in arguments
or disputes with other people and what
it is that we easily can slip into or
start attributing to other people maybe
because we ourselves are doing it I
don't need to go into examples because
there are so many out there I think you
can figure out how to apply this quite
easily but you should be on guard
against your own Tendencies to do this
including attributing bad faith to other
people when you might yourself be in bad
faith in arguing debating investigating
with them